dis moi ce que tu manges je te dirai
d'où tu viens sao paulo pour le géant
d'amérique latine des bords plus d'un
million de fois chaque jour pas de doute
l'ogre brésilien fera du sang italien
dans les veines
les italiens se sont eux qui en plus
d'un siècle ont construit la ville
[Musique]
et la mémoire vivante de cette épopée
c'est le propriétaire du plus vieux
restaurants italiens de tout le brésil
il s'agit d' angelo le maestro de la
mandoline
[Musique]
on
lina vide et d'autre tout tout ce
week-end en vigueur
chez musigo le loup et le mental
[Musique]
il est fringant jello pourtant il à 92
printemps est toujours du souffle pour
sa clarinette son premier amour de
musiciens
cette cantine il l'a achetée en jouant
de la musique dans les cafés et les
cabarets de sao paulo sa vie est un
roman elle a même inspiré une telenovela
un de ces fameux feuilleton à l'eau de
rose dont les brésiliens ont le secret
terra nostra retrace la grande migration
italien entre 1870 à 1950 à cette époque
on quittent massivement une italie sans
perspectives ils sont plus d'un million
et demi à venir travailler ici d'abord
dans les exploitations de café puis dans
les usines d'un sao paulo en pleine
expansion la plupart étaient des paysans
illettrés mais en 1950 sur le bateau
angelo lui c'était l'artiste
[Musique]
à
à québec
la vie d'angelo c'est une histoire du
20e siècle des anecdotes il en a à la
pelle ap les années de guerre en 42 en
tunisie puis l'aventuré brésilienne sa
femme qui accouche à la descente du
bateau et ses filles et ses petites
filles
qu'est ce qui vous manque le plus de
l'italie du tout
charme du cac et onspex d'aïd al
taï chi tous deux que vous mourrez
sjoberg
angelo est l'un des derniers habitants
de sao paulo né en italie
car après lui dans les années 50
l'immigration italienne s'est arrêté
pourtant le chiffre officiel est
impressionnant
aujourd'hui parmi les 20 millions d'âmes
de la mégalopole 60% revendique un aïeul
italien d origine dont certains
descendants ont fait leur fond commerce
tout va bien madame mais vous monsieur
comment allez-vous
toujours un mot et un sourire pour le
client leonardo a le négoce dans la peau
il est le deuxième frère de la maison
familiale qui happe et à
son tour pas c'est à dire qui se
respecte commence par de bons antipathie
20 au beau livre panettones la maison
qui happe et en importe la crème des
produits italiens les caps et à ce sont
les membres fondateurs du marché
municipal de sao paulo ouvert en 1932
aujourd'hui encore le marché le coeur
commerçant de la ville et le bon goût de
l'italie il ya toujours une place de
choix ici les caps et à travailler en
famille à l'italienne il y à la femme de
leonardo claudette c'est elle qui fait
les comptes
son frère junior eduardo à la vente
et la mama natalina sucreries
il marche et c'est toute ma vie ce sont
les débuts et ce sera ma faim
natalina 80 ans fait partie de cette
première génération d'italiens né à sao
paulo elle est fière de ses racines
latines mais elle est avant tout paoli
cela est brésilienne notre mamie gâteau
n'a mis les pieds que deux fois en
italie
c'est très mignon là bas mais je préfère
le brésil
il y avait plusieurs teams immigrants
notre famille est venue ici pour
construire une nouvelle nation
sao paulo un siècle et demi d'expansion
permanente qui a vu grandir le commerce
des pierres pétards au fil des
générations
ces marchés en tout a commencé pour ma
famille mon grand père mon père est
maintenant pour mon neveu adrian
adriano le voici au milieu du dépôt où
il gère les stocks de l'entreprise
il est le quatrième chapitre du roman
familial c'est lui qui aura la charge de
faire prospérer la marque kia péta au
21e siècle
c'est l'avenir de la famille qui est en
jeu notre famille reposent sur ce
business
pour l'heure adriano apprend les
ficelles du métier avec son papa
troisième frère et grand manitou de la
maison et voici nos boss ensemble ils
consolident lanka au cap et à car leur
nom c'est bien plus qu'un stand sur le
marché local aujourd'hui cap et à nkouo
emploie près de 50 personnes et arrose
tout le pays en produisent italien des
avions décollent tous les jours chargés
de marchandises et le papa joue les vrp
aux quatre coins du brésil
pour le travail cette année j'ai fait 92
voyage rien qu'au brésil
tout cela ils le doivent aux anciens feu
le grand père et l'arrière grand père
pierre bêta dont les portraits trônent
au dessus du bureau
des portraits on l'aimé là une fois que
tu es mort moi je ne veux pas qu'on
affiche ma bobine ici trop vite
à regarder c'est intéressant c'est notre
premier véhicule de livraison
carlo qui a peta a débarqué en 1908 à
sao paulo analphabète et sans un sou en
poche à l'époque la ville comptait cinq
cent mille habitants dont 300 milles
italien la légende veut qu'un oncle
arrivé plus tôt lui ai donné trois sacs
de pommes de terre pour commencer le
commerce la saga cap état pouvait
débuter
depuis tout petit j'ai toujours
travaillé avec mes parents j'ai grandi
comme ça c'est toute façon faire très
italienne
il a fallu se battre c'est pas facile de
maintenir un business sur autant de
temps et de conserver la famille
la famille qui a peta est à l'image de
la ville
parti de rien il ya un siècle et le fils
aujourd'hui vers la prospérité
[Musique]
il va pas se laisser taquiné par les
chauffards du quartier angelo ici il est
chez lui
quand il n'est pas dans son restaurant
notre patron musiciens fresnes dans le
quartier il y est connu comme le loup
blanc
hergé
[Musique]
le quartier d'angelo c'est bisciglia
entièrement bâtie par des italiens fin
19e
l'église en fut le premier édifice
catholique mais pas trop pratique angelo
l'adorent elle le ramène au pays et à la
musique
venez là vous veniez j'avais ma limite
schubert mais autant que les autres
quand on attaque une aide
s'il fait pleurer tout le monde angelo
c'est peut-être parce qu'il rappelle
tout le monde aux origines perdu ses
vrais italiens après lui il y en aura
plus dans le quartier l'italie sera
alors un fantasme tout au plus une
spécialité culinaire ou un match de foot
à la télé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier avec la
défaite de milan
hier à la télé vous avez perdu contre
barcelone c'est quoi ce match
il n'y a plus cette joie italienne comme
il y avait autrefois
avant les portes et les fenêtres étaient
grandes ouvertes et les familles assises
sur des chaises à discuter dans la rue
et ça malheureusement ça n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
à sao paulo tout change très vite mais
quelle que soit l'époque angelo a
toujours le même plaisir à mettre son
grain de sel italien dans la vie du
quartier
chez les caps état reste une valeur
typiquement italienne qui n'est pas près
de se perdre la famille
bonjour ma vie mon petit fils qu'est ce
qu'il est bon mon petit fils
la veille de quénéhervé
cet après midi ses conseils qualité une
fois par mois tout le monde se réunit
pour tester les nouveaux produits
toute la famille doit aimer pour valider
le produit
même si tu aimes pas tué
le chef dit qu'il faut aimer on avait
sept ou
mamie natalina ne perd pas le nord et
compter sur elle pour transmettre
jusqu'au bout le goût du commerce à
toute la famille
il faut que ça continue quand je ne
serai plus là il faut que ça continue et
qu'on reste fort
la maison qui a peta est devenue grande
mais n'a rien perdu de l'âme du petit
épicier italien du début du 20e siècle
quatre générations qui ont entretenu
l'esprit de conquête des fondateurs de
la ville
[Musique]
les premiers immigrés italiens ont légué
bien plus que leurs noms aux habitants
de sao paulo à travers cinq générations
ils ont fondé la génèse d'une nouvelle
identité celle d'une cité devenue le
parent de tout un pays
[Applaudissements]